sabemos que van a cerrar bares y
restaurantes a partir de las 5 de la
tarde que no se puede circular durante
la noche que están prohibidas todo tipo
de fiesta y de espectáculo musical y que
sí se podrá ir a la playa pero sin
comercio ambulante que es una
característica de las playas urbanas de
río de janeiro lo que hay que ver es si
los cariocas serán capaces de respetar
una semana de restricciones porque en
esas semanas hemos visto una ciudad
abarrotada de gente donde si alguien
llegase sin saber nada pensaría que no
hay una pandemia además hay varios
estados del país que están haciendo lo
mismo entre ellos hablamos ayer de san
paolo pero también para nada bahía santa
catarina que es uno de los estados más
golpeados hay que recordar que en brasil
sigue sin una política nacional de
coordinación de lucha contra la pandemia
y que el presidente llegue bolsonaro se
opone al lock down nacional
hablando de eso valeria cuál ha sido la
reacción del presidente de wilson ario
quien rechaza todo tipo de medidas de
contención para el avance de esta
pandemia
podemos decir que el discurso de bolsón
aaron no ha cambiado a lo largo de un
año hoy ha vuelto a defender la economía
y lo hace la misma semana en que sabemos
que el pib el año pasado cayó un 41 por
ciento es el peor dato de los últimos 30
años aunque es mejor de lo que se
esperaba ahora bien hoy bolsonaro ha
dado más declaraciones cuando menos
polémicas diciendo que los brasileños
tienen que parar de lloriquear y de
quejarse y ha minimizado de nuevo el
efecto de la pandemia y ha dicho que el
desempleo tiene que ser enfrentado ahora
así como las consecuencias económicas de
esta pandemia